[موسيقى]
لذا فإن
دونالد ترامب والجمهوريون المهاجرون
يمثلون التطرف
الذي يهدد أسس
جمهوريتنا
[الموسيقى]
، مصممون
على إعادة هذا البلد إلى الوراء
إلى أمريكا
حيث لا يوجد حق في اختيار
أي حق  الخصوصية
لا حق في منع الحمل ولا الحق في
الزواج بمن تحب
مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي ووزارة العدل
أصبحت وحوشًا شريرة
يسيطر عليها المحامون الأوغاد اليساريون المتطرفون
ووسائل الإعلام الذين يخبرونهم بما يجب
عليهم فعله أيها الناس هناك ومتى
يفعلون ذلك
[موسيقى] من
قبل  أعيننا
يتم الاستيلاء على بلدنا الحبيب من قبل الأشخاص
الذين يحولون الديمقراطيات إلى ديكتاتوريات
وإلى الخراب في نهاية المطاف
يعتقدون أنهم يستطيعون تقسيمنا لكنهم
لا
يستطيعون تقسيمها.
حركة ماغا
هي الأعظم
في
تاريخ بلدنا
ينخرط الديمقراطيون في
محاولة يائسة لمنعني من العودة إلى
البيت الأبيض حيث يعلمون أنني سأقوم بتنظيف
هذه الفوضى مرة أخرى